the following trailer is rated s for
spoilers
i mean you can probably tell from the
title that godzilla fights king kong but
we tell you who wins
if that sort of thing matters to you
in a year where everyone realized we're
at the mercy of nature
the world will sublimate that anxiety
into watching a giant monkey
fight a giant lizard in a perfectly
timed release
before we snap and punch and or kiss the
mailman
i'm scared to see this in a theater not
because the virus i've just completely
forgotten how to interact with people
godzilla vs kong
you've been moderately pleased by all
the legendary kaiju movies so far
now tune in for another bad sober good
with the buzz installment
of the sloppiest franchise running where
character and timeline continuity is
more of a suggestion
featuring characters they forgot to
mention were related characters they
forgot to mention entirely
and characters who forgot they
discovered the earth was hollow in the
last movie
the vortex was a tunnel into the hollow
earth it doesn't matter i knew i was
right
but one thing remains constant
absolutely no one watching
gives a sh about any of it now make with
the monkey fights
ah that's the stuff meet the humans of
the monster verse
because i had to so now you do too
they're just here to yell at what's
going on
even though there's no way any of them
could possibly know that information
this is why godzilla attacked the apex
facility they're trying to replace him
it's the axe it's drawing radiation from
the core like it's charging
yeah it could be a sciantic interface
it's just some lit up tubes man how
would you know that
but don't worry they all have a
backstory whether it's their dead wife
she was my rock my truth dead brother
what really went wrong on your brother's
mission
dead mom or screw it dead everyone
when the storm took over the island it
wiped out the native people
as they carry on the monsterverse
tradition of hiring great actors
then making them say stuff like this
with a straight face right now
godzilla's out there and he's hurting
people and we don't know why
cringe as the overly dramatic dialogue
is way funnier than the intentional
comedy of the film
as you follow along with the most
obnoxious fictional character profession
the podcaster something bad is going on
here a vast
corporate conspiracy brian tyree henry
ranson rapes his way through the
sharpest conspiracy theory jokes of
2007.
the illuminati running shadow economy is
ought to find a hidden colony for the
elite
water they put fluoride in it and millie
bobby brown returns as his kaiju and on
in training
theory is it makes docile easy to
manipulate plus this boy is also there
in this goofy subplot that could be
completely cut without anyone noticing
you only need one group of humans to
follow in these movies okay everyone
else is there to either be squished and
or cheer when godzilla destroys their
home
with a title like godzilla vs kong they
better deliver on the fights
as they pit the titular titans against
each other no less than three times
i mean sure godzilla wins two out of
three because i mean come on
look at the guy and yes kong spends more
time on his back than riley reed
but the film will do everything in its
power to make you root for the big hairy
boy
he's friends with children he loves
snacks and he's got thor zacks
i mean come on the only endearing thing
godzilla does is destroy part of florida
but no versus movie would be complete
without them joining forces at the end
against a surprise third fighter what
the hell is that
what the hell is that what god's name is
mega godzilla
let's make a godzilla a giant jaeger
created to fight godzilla
until he loses human control and fights
godzilla
causing the two beasts to team up
against this man-made atrocity
and all three of them to team up against
the city of hong kong
no wonder this movie is huge in china
so see it on the biggest screen you can
which for most of us right now
is our phone even though it's probably
best suited for one of those theme park
rides with moving seats
that may not be the most intelligent
thing you could be watching
but you know what neither are we and we
spoke this movie into existence back in
from the company who has the rights to
godzilla king kong
and pacific rim so please please please
do a crossover where they all fight each
other and stuff
you're welcome starring
i get knocked down but i get up again
reptile wins just make out already
you're perfect for each other
on today's show we're gonna reveal the
horrible truth
but first i'd like to tell you about
squarespace
billionaires shouldn't exist becca like
a high mecha heidi ho
the chris hemsworth of the brothers
skarsgard let them fire
pre-teen titans and
physics i like titans punch out
okay not trying to kink shame but why
are all these monsters always trying to
spit in each other's mouths
that's not a thing real animals do they
learn this from watching people
that's gross i want to cry so bad
but i don't think i can spare the
moisture
i was hiding under your porch because i
love you
at least they aren't making a karen in
the last manager movie yet
i'm tired of these mother boxes snakes
and this mother boxes plane
you